nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
son visage a fait le tour du monde Macha
Amini une kurde de 22 ans est morte en
détention après avoir été arrêté
mi-septembre à Téhéran par la police des
mœurs pour port du foulard non conforme
à la loi depuis la colère populaire
enflamme les rues de l'Iran en face le
régime multiplie les arrestations les
tortures et les condamnations à mort de
nombreux manifestants fuient cette
répression et trouve refuge au Kurdistan
irakien voisin Kevin Berg bonjour vous
revenez de cette zone du Kurdistan
irakien régulièrement bombardé par la
République islamique d'Iran pourquoi
est-ce là-bas que se retrouvent ceux qui
fuient la répression iranienne et bien
il se retrouve là-bas pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que le Kurdistan
irakien c'est finalement la région la
plus démocratique où les droits de
l'homme sont le plus respectés dans
cette zone qui est quand même entouré
par
adhérents l'Irak et la Syrie ensuite
parce que Macha Amini il faut bien le
rappeler c'est une Iranienne mais une
Iranienne d'origine kurde et beaucoup de
kurde se sont présentés dans toutes ces
manifestations et c'est pour eux la voie
la plus rapide et la plus facile pour
trouver refuge dans une région où on
parle la même langue que et on les
accueille pour prendre soin d'eux et
surtout pour les protéger du régime
iranien alors on va découvrir sur
portage les exilés réalisés par Kevin
Berg et puis on vous retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
27 septembre 11h45 11 jours après la
mort de ma famille arrêtez à Téhéran
pour mauvais port du foulard et morte en
détention des missiles iraniens fattaque
sur une base militaire
même scène il y a quelques jours cette
fois ce sont des drones kamikaze
Iraniens qui frappent
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes au nord de l'Irak au sur
distance région autonome bordée par
l'Iran la Turquie et la Syrie
si l'Iran bombardent aussi durement la
région c'est parce qu'il accuse les
factions armées turques de soutenir le
soulèvement populaire en cours
[Applaudissements]
en réalité le Kurdistan voit arriver
presque quotidiennement des manifestants
Iraniens qui fuient la répression
est désormais le refuge de ces nouveaux
îles idées de la Révolution et il en
paye le prix
l'homme au visage ensanglantés c'est lui
trois jours après l'explosion le
commandant pechner garé basse a eu
beaucoup de chance cette fois bonne idée
on a été bombardé sur toute cette zone
mes amis sont venus me chercher et ils
ont réussi à me faire sortir d'ici
mon ami mzana qui était avec moi est
mort dans cette attaque en moins d'une
heure plus de 10 missiles se sont
abattus sur sa base et ses hommes bilan
dit mort et 21 blessés
[Musique]
un des missiles les plus destructeurs
fabriqués par l'Iran
et ça ce sont les éclats des roquettes
la trace de leurs attaques
ils ont utilisé plusieurs de ces
missiles contre nous la maison
pas le temps de s'attarder la menace
n'est jamais loin
au cours des deux derniers jours nous
avons observé le même drone au-dessus de
nous
ils sont en train de regarder et quand
ils font cela ils préparent quelque
chose de mauvais pour cette raison il
faut partir
l'Iran pense qu'on nous attaquons ici
cela aura un impact sur les
manifestations à l'intérieur de leur
pays
mais nous avons soutenu ces
manifestations et nous n'arrêterons
jamais nous les soutiendrons de plus en
plus nous recueillerons tous les gens
qui ont été blessés dans les
manifestations en Iran
parmi ces manifestants qui ont fui
l'Iran il y a Adar 18 ans ce jeune
iranien d'origine toujours devient tout
juste de rejoindre les pêches mergat
il y a encore quelques jours il était
livreur le voilà
le jour où Marseille est morte les
manifestations ont commencé
je ne pouvais pas rester sans rien faire
j'ai senti que je devais aller
manifester
la police l'a tué à cause de son voile
descend dans la rue et Antonne des
slogans pour la liberté des femmes et
contre le régime au péril de sa vie
on criait
femmei puis un jour pendant une
manifestation on m'a arrêté et je suis
allé en prison pendant 7 jours
les policiers me battaient et me
torturer il me frappait avec une
matraque tous les jours
ensuite ils m'ont demandé de donner des
informations de coopérer avec eux et
puis de travailler comme un espion
infiltré pour le régime iranien j'ai
refusé
le pouvoir peut-être puni de mort à Dar
lui a été torturé
alors j'ai été livré au service secret
eux ont utilisé un produit chimique pour
me brûler ici dans le dos
ils m'ont brûlé puis ils ont continué à
me torturer pendant au moins quatre
heures
j'étais alors merci
du régime des Iraniens de plus en plus
nombreux comme Adar passe la frontière
pour rejoindre les commandes au kurde et
faire tomber le régime des Molas parmi
eux des femmes bien décidé en découdre
pour les retrouver il faut traverser ces
montagnes rejoindre un lieu tenu secret
à quelques kilomètres seulement de la
frontière iranienne
[Musique]
au cœur de ce commando expérimenté de
nouvelles Sadia 18 ans et nous revente
se forme au maniement des armes
toutes de iranienne l'uniqueure de
l'autre nom elles sont arrivées il y a 2
semaines et sont recherchés par les
autorités pour avoir manifesté
devant notre caméra elle doivent couvrir
leur visage leur famille sont encore en
Iran
[Musique]
elle allait rentrer à l'université quand
les manifestations ont commencé
là-bas en tant que femme je n'avais
aucun droit
ils ont donné une arme et me voilà pêche
merguard je suis ici pour défendre des
droits que je n'ai jamais eu auparavant
comme nous Sadia a laissé des proches
derrière elle un choix difficile aux
conséquences lourdes
depuis que j'ai rejoint les pêches
mergats ma famille en Iran subit des
menaces et des pressions ils sont
interrogés on leur demande où est votre
fille que fait-elle
vous devez nous la livrer vous devez la
ramener il parle à ma famille comme ça
il prendront ma sœur à la place ils
l'ont dit à mon père
je ne sais pas ce qui lui arriverait si
il la prenait il la ferait disparaître
c'est ce qu'ils font toujours avec leurs
prisonniers
pour ne pas sombrer les filles
s'entraînent dur
je veux être comme elle
sous son apparence résolue Sadia blessé
à une jambe par un coup de matraque
n'est pas très sereine
je veux accompagner mes amis me battre
elles vont se battre pour notre patrie
je veux être avec elle je veux faire
partie de ce groupe
plus expérimenté les autres filles
s'entraînent sans relâche dans des
conditions qui se veulent les plus
proches du réel
les exercices s'enchaînent toute la
journée et se termine toujours par un
champ patriotique
chaque combattante au de son foulard de
sa tête un signe de solidarité avec les
Iraniennes
la liberté mais surtout la paix c'est ce
que cherche ces familles iraniennes qui
ont quitté leur pays à lattes elles sont
installées dans des habitations de
fortune isolées au confort sommaire
eux ne prennent pas les armes ils
résistent en silence
femme au foyer ils ont fui l'Iran il y a
une semaine avec leur fils après avoir
été repéré pendant une manifestation
ma femme a peur de parler parce que
notre famille est à la merci des
autorités iraniennes
c'est pour ça que notre visage est
couvert
on ne peut pas être exposé pour ne pas
mettre plus de pression sur notre
famille en Iran
le régime là-bas est pire calcaida
terrorisé par le régime qu'elle a fui
wajia a mis du temps à nous parler
beaucoup de filles qui manifestaient qui
se battaient pour leurs droits et elles
ont été tuées à cause de cela les forces
et de mauvais traitement envers les
femmes elle ne peuvent même pas aller
chez le coiffeur ou se maquiller elles
n'ont aucun droit les femmes n'ont aucun
droit là-bas je suis très triste pour
elle je n'ai pas les mots
ça y est des wadjiha craignent des
représailles ils prennent régulièrement
des nouvelles de leur famille rester en
Iran
dieu merci ils vont bien mais de temps
en temps la police vient à la maison et
il demande où est-il qu'est-ce qu'il
fait
la famille m'a dit que la situation est
vraiment mauvaise
ils arrêtent beaucoup de jeunes il les
battent et ils les mettent en prison une
centaine d'entre eux ont été arrêtés
dieu merci tu n'es pas là-bas si tu
étais resté tu serais dans la pire des
situations
avant de nous quitter wajia nous demande
de la filmer une dernière fois de dos
pour ne pas risquer la vie de ses
proches
[Musique]
dans la montagne ce soir là nous partons
retrouver Sadia et Nour celles qui ont
choisi les armes
[Musique]
toutes ces femmes comme dans des
conditions précaires sans aucune
intimité mais pour Sadia il faut en
passer par là
je ne suis pas aussi entraînée que ces
filles
mais quand je les regarde je me dis que
je veux y arriver moi aussi
et ça me motive pour continuer à
m'entraîner
la bataille que l'on mène ici et pour
toutes les femmes du monde elle devrait
avoir les mêmes droits partout
en attendant de retourner en Iran pour
se battre pour leur liberté elle
finiront cette nuit comme toutes les
autres avec un poème adressé à l'Iran
leur pays
[Musique]
un poème comme un symbole celui de la
résistance de cette poignée de femmes
face à la brutalité du régime iranien
voilà pour ce reportage signé Kevin
Berck Kevin qui est avec nous au plateau
dans quelles conditions avez-vous pu
tourner sur portage au Kurdistan irakien
alors pour aller au Kurdistan et
finalement c'est assez facile pour des
journalistes français tout simplement
parce que l'État français et la région
du Kurdistan entretiennent plutôt de
bonnes relations ce qui devient plus
compliqué c'est une fois qu'on est sur
place parce que vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure la région est régulièrement
bombardée par l'Iran et les Iraniens qui
sont là et bien il reste quand même
caché que ça soit ceux qui ont rejoint
les forces militaires Kurdes qui sont
dans des plans d'entraînement ou dans
des bases militaires ou ceux qui sont
tout simplement réfugiés et puis tous
ces réfugiés ils ont laissé derrière eux
une famille en Iran sur laquelle on met
beaucoup de pression pour savoir où ils
sont pour les retrouver donc il faut
d'abord
donner leur donner des guérités
nécessaires c'est ça il faut d'abord
leur donner la confiance nécessaire que
effectivement on gardera bien leur
visage masqué et surtout pour ne
révélera pas les lieux où ils sont alors
comment réagit le gouvernement de de de
cette province autonome irakienne qui
est le Kurdistan et comment réagit
Bagdad de choses différentes et bien
pour ce qui est du Kurdistan irakien eux
ils sont plutôt ravis d'accueillir ces
réfugiés d'abord parce qu'il lutte
contre le régime iranien depuis
plusieurs décennies maintenant et aussi
parce qu'ils ont soutenu ces
manifestations dès le début dès la mort
de Massa à mini donc pour eux c'est une
bonne chose d'accueillir ces réfugiés
d'abord pour les mettre en sécurité ce
sont beaucoup de réfugiés Turcs qui sont
de la même ethnie finalement que et puis
aussi parce que certains viennent
rejoindre leur force militaire pour
combattre le régime iranien donc pour ce
régime kurde irakien et bien c'est une
bonne chose en revanche pour Bagdad
c'est plus compliqué parce que l'Irak
entretient plutôt de bonnes relations
avec l'Iran qui met une énorme pression
à l'Irak pour intervenir dans cette zone
du Kurdistan irakien augmenter les
contrôles stopper cette afflux de
réfugiés mais d'un autre côté l'Irak et
bien ils ne peuvent pas non plus
vraiment s'introduire dans le Kurdistan
irakien parce que
on a des militaires pêche feria formé
habitués au combat et intervenir ça
serait finalement peut-être créer un
conflit interne à l'Irak et ça ils
veulent l'éviter donc l'Irak il se
retrouve dans une position vraiment ils
doivent marcher sur un fil Kevin Berg de
retour du Kurdistan merci beaucoup Kevin
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]